I spoke at an education Summit from
Microsoft this is when Steve Ballmer was
CEO I spoke at an education Summit for
Microsoft and most of the executives
spent most of their presentations
talking about how to beat Apple
a few months later coincidence I spoken
at education Summit for Apple
and there all of the leaders spent all
of their presentations talking about how
to help teachers teach and how to help
students learn one was obsessed with
their vision and where they were going
the other one was trying to beat their
competition
at the end of my talk with Microsoft
they gave me a gift the Zune this was
Microsoft's response to the iPad when it
was a thing
and this little piece of technology was
quite fantastic I have to tell you
at the end of my Apple talk I was
sharing a taxi with a senior Apple
Executives and I couldn't help myself I
had to I had to make some problems I had
to start and I turned to my said you
know Microsoft gave me their new Zune it
is so much better than my iPod Touch
and he looked at me and he said I have
no doubt and the conversation was over
because he understood that sometimes
you're ahead and sometimes you're behind
there's no such thing as winning and
where Microsoft Microsoft was obsessed
with beating apple apple was obsessed
without doing itself and a few years
later they introduced the iPhone
rendering both Zune and the iPod
completely obsolete that's a perfect
example of infinite minded thinking
where you actually are not trying to
beat the competition you actually spend
every moment trying to outdo yourself
and it's the source of innovation
inspiration and so many other things